the single greatest thing that you can
do to improve the quality of your life
is to take responsibility for it no more
blaming your parents or the country or
the government or your family or your
community or your education no more
blaming other people it may not be your
fault where you are right now but it is
your responsibility alone to fix it you
didn't pick where you started but you
can choose where you end up so I
remember growing up my parents were very
hardcore education you see my parents
behind me here I'm eight or nine here
this is my parents and we were middle
class family we weren't poor by any
stretch but we also you know we're not
rich and my parents invested basically
everything they had into our education
and so we didn't spend money on a lot of
other stuff I remember driving into my
school and all of the friends all the
other people at the school had all these
fancy cars given a Mercedes or BMW from
their family you know my family had a
reliant cake car just because my family
you know prioritized education and I
remember used to get made fun of for the
car and I never went on the vacations
that they went on and I didn't have the
fancy watches and all that other stuff
and there was one friend of mine who was
kind of in a similar boat where his
parents you know weren't making a lot of
money invested everything that they had
into his education too and so we we
quickly became friends but it's funny
now because I never blame my parents I
I'm super grateful for that they
invested so much and that they cared and
it's on me like if my business doesn't
work out it's not their fault up until
you know you can potentially move out I
don't know what age you want to say if
it's 14 15 16 18 but after a certain age
you're an adult you have to take
responsibility for your life need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael we made
these videos probably because you are
the most ambitious person in your circle
you know you're capable of more and you
get that Push by surround yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Aaron Carmichael
and my take on his top 10 rules for
Success enjoy
rule number two build momentum the only
thing missing in your life is momentum
you're a genius you've got great ideas
you are the Michael Jordan of something
the only thing that is stopping you is
your ability to do difficult things and
start building momentum I think for so
many people it's not just doing the
thing that scares you first first thing
in the morning it's doing it at all most
people just don't do it at all you've
got a great idea you know it can work
but you're afraid of judgment you don't
know where to start you're afraid of it
being not perfect and people telling you
that you suck and you failing publicly
you're afraid of all that stuff and so
you don't do anything you got your foot
on the gas and break at the same time
knowing that you're capable of more
knowing that you have greatness in here
but then being too afraid to go off and
execute it and so I think not just
starting your day with the thing that
scares you it's just moving doing
something anything just getting started
on your crazy idea it's not that you're
leaving it to the afternoon it's that
most people aren't doing it at all so I
was on a call with an entrepreneur
friend of mine yesterday and she was
upset she was frustrated she had decided
last year mid last year right June July
last year that she needed to let
somebody go on her team this person was
being toxic in their environment was
still producing results for the company
but just being a big drag on the company
on the culture and on herself as trying
to lead this team of people and so she
decided I gotta let this person go it's
six seven months later now and she still
hasn't done it she still hasn't done it
because she's afraid of maybe not
finding the right person to replace the
impact of having to go through training
and hiring all over again and she just
hasn't made the decision the biggest
problem is she has not decided and so I
said
when is this gonna matter to you you
decided you decided right last year six
seven eight months ago and you still
haven't done the thing and she said well
if it gets to a year and I still haven't
done it then I have to go up and do it
and this is where your standards come
into place
you belong after you've made a decision
do you actually start to do something
about it in her case her standards were
a year in that she decided but then a
year later that's when that's when it's
too much that's when it's gone too far
that she hasn't done it in a year now
it's too much I want you to shorten that
Gap
teach yourself that as soon as you
decide you do something you act you put
the plan into motion because you don't
have that many years left I look at her
you know she's she's not old yet she's
not midlife yet but you don't have that
many years left
and this isn't even that big a decision
whatever is in front of you is not
actually that big a decision there are
much bigger decisions I had it may feel
like a big decision it may feel like it
but after you've done it and you get
through it you realize huh I could do
that again and there's another bigger
decision in the head you need to shorten
the gap between deciding that you want
to do something and actually taking
action towards it rule number three
learn from success people who you spend
time with is who you become it's why I
created this channel so you and I can
hang out with people like Warren Buffett
you may never meet Warren Buffett but
you can learn from him you can be
inspired by him and you can change your
life for the better by consuming this
kind of content I love violent success
because I learned from Bill Gates Bill
Gates was the first guy that I modeled
success from I had a software company
was struggling was making no money I
told my partner I quit and then I asked
myself somebody has done this before I
can't be the first person to try to
build a software company it can't be
this hard please somebody's figured this
out and the only person who came to my
mind was Bill Gates who started my
Microsoft I hadn't been really that
interested in Reading I hadn't been that
interested in studying success I was
just trying to come up with ideas myself
and I was desperate right I told my
partner I quit I was desperate I was at
rock bottom and so I said Somebody's
figure this out I can only think of Bill
Gates and Microsoft and so I studied his
company and how he started the zero to
one right how did he make his first
Milling what did he do and it was
through Partnerships and I applied that
strategy to my business and and shortly
I have to have my first deal for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars and
I felt like I won the lottery and after
that I had a pattern to use over and
over and over again and since then it's
been 20 years now of sharing that with
you guys it's been for me constant
learning it's the name of my channel
modeling success it's why I have all
these people behind me on the wall
that's why I make these videos every day
it's why I love learning from people
like Warren Buffett and Steve Jobs and
Kanye and Oprah and all these people
because they can shift you because they
shifted me and the thing that they give
you at least for me they give me one the
inspiration the motivation the idea that
look at what they started with that they
could start from there and then end up
at this new place why can't I you you
already have more resources than Bill
Gates did when he started you have more
resources than Kanye did than Steve Jobs
did when they started you're in a better
position than they were they would have
to create amazing things go study
Oprah's story and tell me that you're in
a worse position than Oprah was when she
started you're not
you're not and so it's inspiration the
other part is tactics ideas specific
strategies right Bill Gates doing
Partnerships through distributorships
all of these things learning from that
and saying hey I can apply that to my
business maybe not 100 but it gets you
eighty percent of the way and instead of
you figuring out the entire solution you
just have to figure out how to bridge
that 20 Gap at the end it's much easier
it can lead to your success rule number
4. be willing to work hard there is no
longer any acceptable reason why you
can't get the mentors that you're after
and start winning the opportunities that
are in front of you right now did not
exist for your parents and it's only
getting easier but you
sue your part you still
still have to want it
actually less about winning
where you came from and much more about
how badly do you want it and how much
you're gonna put in to get after it
because if you are willing to put in the
work you can beat out somebody with a
thousand times more resources than you
so every night I go on Twitch and I
stream My League of Legends games
twitch.tv believe team here and there's
a guy who joined me last night from the
Philippines so it's from the Philippines
and he says that his goal is to be a
professional League of Legends player
and the challenge is not a big League of
Legends scene in the Philippines it's no
professional teams there's only one
player right now named dick Smithy who's
a jungler where did he go he was jungler
for Team Liquid and he signed with a new
team it escapes him right now there's
one person who was born in the
Philippines who's a pro player right now
and makes his living as a professional
League of Legends player this guy joins
my live stream last night and he says
he's a support player from the
Philippines and that's his ambition he's
gonna grind it out he wants to get
noticed he wants to get picked up he
wants to be a professional League of
Legends player
the crazy thing is that's actually
possible
it's actually possible for him to do it
it's actually possible for him to get
training for him to get mentorship for
him to reach out to for him to get in
contact with people here he is he's in
the Philippines I'm in Canada
and we're talking and we're connecting
on my live stream
it's actually possible it wasn't
possible even 10 years ago definitely
not for his parents you look at what his
parents are doing where they came from
you could have some dream but at that
time the dream was probably just to come
to North America or just to have this
one little thing that that existed in
the world currently right The Limited
mindset because there were limited
opportunities but right now the
opportunities are insane you have a
thing called the internet
people didn't have it before the
opportunities are insane you are
competing against the world which is bad
for a lot of North Americans
but it's amazing for anybody who's
outside or amazing for anybody who's
willing to work hard it's not even bad
for North Americans it's bad for anybody
who's lazy who's slow who's maybe had
things handed to them there's a lot of
people in North America who had nothing
hands in them but they're willing to
work hard if you are willing to work
hard if you are willing to show yourself
it's never been easier to win Justin
Bieber got discovered on YouTube you
don't need to have a manager anymore you
don't have to go through the system you
don't want to I got a publisher for my
deal but you don't want to have a
publisher you don't Publishers reject
you great go off and self-publish David
Goggins did lots of people created
number one bestsellers just from
self-publishing you can bet on yourself
if you're willing to work hard if you're
willing to put in the effort it's never
been easier to win and so I look at this
guy from the Philippines it might be
easier for me right me sitting here in
Canada if my goal was to be a
professional League of Legends player
sure it might be easier for me sure I
might have more resources sure I can
afford coaching and go to tournaments
and meet people
but it's also never been easier for him
because in the past it would have been
only available to me
now it's available to anybody and if he
has the heart and the hustle and the
drive and the intention and the will to
go off and do it every day he can Crush
someone like me even if I have a
thousand times more resources than him
and you can too also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five change your standards
you are where you are in life and
business because of your standards it's
just not important enough for you yet to
hit that next level for you for me for
all of us we've settled we've settled
for what currently is and haven't
demanded from ourselves that we reach
that next level change your standards
change your life so I was recently
talking to Alex on my team and he helps
me run Toronto dance salsa the largest
dance school for salsa in North America
probably and he recently went through
this weight loss challenge and he lost I
don't know I want to say 30 pounds and
now he's sticking to this really thin
line of between 150 and 155 pounds
that's his goal that's his standard when
he's when he's getting close to 155 he
slows down on the eating and when he's
around 150 he has a little bit more and
he's constantly staying in this band
because he set a new study for himself
even though he might have been 180 or
185 before
now anywhere close to 155 is going to be
too much like that's it that's my new
standard that's the lowest I'm gonna go
which is crazy high compared to what he
was before he's now trying to bring that
same standard to his business so what
he's trying to do every day now is if
you follow him on Instagram as he's
posting at the end of the day how proud
he is of the effort he put in
proud as he of the effort that he put in
out of 10. and sometimes you see it's
5.5 sometimes you see it's a seven and
every now and then it's an eight or even
a 9. how proud he is of the effort that
he put in this is now the area where he
needs to raise his standards and I was
talking to him yesterday and a big
breakthrough that happened was said Alex
you lost 30 pounds man or more from your
weight loss Journey now the idea of
being over 155 is crazy when used to be
180 right or 185 it's crazy you need to
take that same approach to your business
to your effort that you're proud of
yourself every day for what you're doing
anything under eight should be
considered a cheat day
anything under eight is like you had to
cheat day on your diet
every now and then on his weight loss
Journey he had a cheetah he had a moment
of weakness he he went for a giant pizza
and a cake because he was starving and
he couldn't control himself but it was
these one-off moments right it was like
once every three weeks or something and
he continued down
that now needs to be your daily effort
if it's under eight that's like you're
eating cake and pizza
eight needs to be the new water line but
if you're getting close to it's like
holy cow I can't I need to work harder I
need to I need to accomplish I need to
go off and do just like 155 now is that
Benchmark for himself and put into those
terms made sense for him because he had
higher standards now for himself in what
he ate in how he took care of his body
than he did for what he was doing into
his business and so it's the same thing
for you you want to grow you want to get
better you want to improve you have to
raise your standards
you have to now not settle for where
you're at because where you're at is
good this is the problem good as the
enemy of great right where you're at
it's good it's good it's not amazing but
it doesn't suck because if it sucked if
you hated it every day you would have to
find a way out but because it's good you
don't do it you don't change
it's not important enough for you to
want to get to that next step rule
number six treat your money as a tool
most people grew up with an unhealthy
view of money some people think that
money is everything that the next person
you see the next customer you talk to
that's your next suit that's your next
car and other people think that money is
the root of all
right or the love of money is the root
of all evil right to make money you're
evil you're slimy you're gross you're
ripping people off most people grow up
in one of those two camps that's the
lesson that's been taught you by your
parents the truth is money is just a
tool money is an amazing tool that lets
you accomplish amazing things and if you
are an entrepreneur and want to have
success making money has to be in your
top five list of priorities if it is not
in your top five then you're not making
money but it can't be number one money
can't be your number one priority there
has to be something that is more
important than it and that's your
purpose I don't really usually talk a
lot about money on my videos
um maybe I should maybe I should talk
more about it I think it's important I
think there's just so much out there
that seems to be money money money money
that I'm trying to go against it to say
like purpose is number one you have
you're built to serve if you're just
chasing money you're never gonna win I
think I see too many entrepreneurs just
chasing money and so a lot of the
content that I make is more Purpose
Driven but there's still there's still I
think a lot of people who are Purpose
Driven who've started the business for
the right reasons and they don't know
how to make money and so maybe I need to
switch up some of the content that I
make as well to help change the
perspective of our money my personal
view is I hate spending money till I'm
making money
I love making money it's not number one
right serving believing entrepreneurs is
number one but again it's in the top
five because if I didn't make money I
wouldn't have a team I wouldn't have
people to help me make this video it'd
be me by myself trying to put together
one piece of content you know a week or
maybe a day just you know filming by
myself but instead I have this team of
people who I'm super appreciative of and
I can afford that because I'm making
money doing the business that I'm doing
rule number seven do scary things doing
what you are afraid of is your path to
success every time you take on something
new that scares you that pushes your
comfort zone that requires you to
stretch on the other side of that scary
thing is the new you who is now capable
of more most people they shrink from
scary things
because they're scary but if you want to
win if you want to hit your ambitious
goals then you have to teach yourself
that you do scary things so I recently
came back from two pretty significant
speaking gigs uh in my career as I'm as
I'm building up and speaking on bigger
stages the first was when I was speaking
of Brendan burchard's event and it's his
growth.com and event and Brendan one of
the greatest speakers in the world
invited me to come and talk to his group
of couple thousand people and then I
went to Ed mylett's event just recently
in Whistler and this is a smaller group
100 so people but they pay sixty
thousand dollars a year to be a part of
his program and so they're coming to
learn from the best he sandwiched me
between David Goggins and Peyton Manning
so it's David Goggins and then me and
then Peyton Manning that was the lineup
and so
when I was backstage at the Brendan
event
I remember moments before going on stage
I was the most scared that I'd been in a
long time the most nervous and most
anxious I was afraid of disappointing
people my biggest fear is letting people
down my biggest fear is that I'm going
to let Brendan down and Dean grazios who
they both brought me there and I was
just gonna suck on stage that was my
biggest fear and so I had a mini panic
attack backstage five minutes before
going up I have this mini panic attack
and I'm forgetting what I'm gonna say I
I imagine myself going on stage and just
blanking out
and I tell myself I'm Evan Carmichael I
do difficult things I love difficult
things if I don't do difficult things
I'm never going to accomplish great
things so I have to do difficult things
I love it I thrive on difficult things
and then I remembered what I was gonna
say and then I went out and I did my
thing
and now when I went to Ed's event
I wasn't as nervous I wasn't as afraid I
was still scared I was still afraid of
letting down at my left letting down
Andy Priscilla who they both brought me
there
being between David Goggins and Peyton
Manning and just being out Shawn uh you
know everybody knows them they may not
know me all of it all of the fears and
doubts but less than what I had at
Brendan's event not because it wasn't as
big a deal but because I had just done
it
because speaking on Sage a couple
thousand people at Brendan's event and
having that panic attack and getting
through it
changed Who I Was Made Me Stronger made
me more capable of doing the next thing
and the next thing was Ed's thing and so
if I hadn't gone to Brendan's I would be
terrified going to Ed's thing
so every time you take on these
difficult challenges
you might have the panic attack you
might have the anxiety inside you might
have that little voice to say you can't
do it what if you fail what if you
disappoint people what if you lose
respect what if it doesn't work out
but what you know what's worse you know
what's worse than going up and failing
not trying
not doing it
finding some reason finding some excuse
to say you're sick you're busy you can't
make it but in the back of your head
you know you're just afraid and the last
thing you want to do is teach yourself
that when you are afraid that when you
have an opportunity in front of you and
you're afraid to do it that you say no
you don't want to teach yourself that
you teach yourself the opposite that
when you're afraid that when there's
something in front of you that you want
to do but you're scared you're anxious
you're worried about letting people down
that you jump in
and you say I'm all in because I do
scary things rule number eight find your
own balance most people suck at creating
work-life balance or Harmony because
you're constantly comparing what you're
doing to other people's schedules of all
the things that you need to figure out
in life what balance means to you is
among the most important Jeff Bezos
jokes about optimizing his toothbrushing
routine because he's trying to maximize
his efficiency while Warren Buffett
reads for five to six hours every day
you can't do both and you need to stop
comparing yourself to someone who you're
not it's crazy how much balance and
scheduling comes up I think most people
are lost I think I think again the
biggest problem is you're just comparing
yourself to other people and then you
don't know where to stand you don't know
what rock to stand on and so you feel
like you're pulled in a thousand
different directions when I went on my
tour this year and I'm sure it's going
to come up on the next one again people
kept asking that what does balance mean
to you how do I find balance to my life
and I used to joke one of the funniest
jokes I told and I'm not that funny so
this is this is one of the funny moments
um was when I was talking about the Rock
and The Rock has his routine where he's
working out for four hours a day he has
to work out for four hours a day and so
when he's doing his movies he wakes up
five hours before he has to be on set
and he'll work out for his four hours
and he'll do two times cardio and two
times weights and then go to the you
know go to his trailer shower and then
head head out to the movies and he's
only sleeping four to five hours a night
when he's on set
I think that's crazy but I don't look
like the Rock and that's when people
would laugh because I don't look like
the rock but it's true people will try
to take on the Rock schedule but you
have other priorities
what the Rock values isn't the same
thing as you value there may be some
overlap and some similarities and
there's nothing wrong with trying on the
hat there's nothing wrong with
attempting to do it there's nothing
wrong with seeing how it fits right to
get pieces to say hey I'm going to try
meditating I'm going to try working out
I'm going to try making a video I'm
going to try morning Pages I'm gonna
awesome great yes
but then to judge yourself to say well
I'm not able to stay consistent on that
it's not what you should be doing
because you want to work out four hours
a day and you want to read five hours a
day like Warren Buffett and you want to
optimize your toothbrush routine like
Jeff Bezos and you want to do all these
different things but it's too many hours
in a day what you have to figure out is
how does balance look like for you and
then not be ashamed to go off and live
it when everybody else thinks you're
nuts rule number nine structure your
life most people never hit their goals
because they don't structure their life
towards actually accomplishing those
goals you can say that you want
something you can say that this is your
ambition and your goal but unless it's
in your calendar unless you start
actually working towards it you're never
going to accomplish it dreams Day Dreams
because there is no momentum let's talk
about how to get it one of the common
questions I get asked when I'm doing my
live stream when I'm doing my my
interviews when I'm doing my my tour my
stops people almost always will ask me
how many hours of sleep do you get when
you go to bed when you get up how much
do you sleep every night right now I'm
sleeping nine hours a day I sleep nine
hours I did a sleep study I was sleeping
around eight and getting and was still
tired when I woke up and so I went and
did an overnight sleep study and they
told me I'm looking for the hack I'm
like hey you're you're deficient in
magnesium so just take these and you can
sleep seven and be normal
he said no nothing wrong with you you
just need to sleep nine hours a night
that's healthy for you like what that's
healthy are you kidding me what are you
talking about nobody Sleeps nine hours a
night he's like yeah between six and ten
is actually that's the normal range the
whole eight hours a night is a myth so I
felt bad and I'm still trying to hack it
so I sleep nine hours a night I don't
wake up to an alarm
and people assume that I am I'm Only
Sleeping three four or five hours a
night because of how productive I am
during the day this is it right you
could sleep 12 hours a night and crush
it in the other 12 hours most people
default to think they needed to wake up
an hour really say well if I wake up at
5am or at 4 a.m I'm gonna be more
productive if you are not productive for
16 hours a day then add in an extra hour
to that's not going to make you that
much more productive the problem isn't
what time you wake up the problem is
what you're doing with the hours that
you're awake and so as much as possible
what I try to do is make every second
intentional not always able to achieve
that especially not every second but but
I try to make everything intentional I
try to make every where I'm spending
time is intentional I'm in the present
I'm not thinking about something else
I'm here with you guys making this video
right now all I think about is this
video that I'm making for you right now
where is Nina right now I don't know
where's my cell phone well it's right
here because I can see it but where are
my keys I don't know where are my dogs I
don't know what am I doing after this I
have no idea
I'm focused and I'm with you right now
most people live in the past most people
are thinking about what could have been
most people are regretting the decisions
that they made and they're
procrastinating because they're afraid
of doing things because they don't want
to do things
all things that prevent you from
actually doing
that's the biggest problem you're a
genius you're the best in the world at
something you can't go off and make
amazing things the problem is your time
is not being used efficiently it's not
being as effectively either you haven't
structured your life to help you
accomplish your goals look at your big
goals look at your big goals like what's
the next big goal that you have for
yourself you may not have one if that's
that if you don't have one then you got
to figure out what your purpose is
because that's the greatest thing of all
time right get the book build the serve
you'll figure it out you'll be you'll be
ignited
but your next big goal now look at your
calendar are you aligning
what's in your calendar your daily
habits towards you accomplishing your
goals and for most people it's it's no
or you're you have it listed but you're
not doing it because you look at it and
you get afraid and you procrastinate on
it
so trying to cut that down to almost
zero even before making these videos
before making espresso videos I have
a couple minutes of procrastination
um I go and make sure I get my water I
go and maybe have a keto bar just pacing
around a little bit because I'm nervous
about making the videos because I want
them to be the best videos that I've
ever made it's always my intention
but too many people live in hours or
days or months of procrastination
instead of doing it you get the results
by doing it's the only way you will
never get the results by just thinking
about it you can be motivated amazing
you have the mindset awesome that's half
the equation the other half is doing you
have to actually just go out there and
do you need to structure your life
to allow you to accomplish your goals
room
you don't love it you don't know much
about it but so many people are talking
about it and it looks like an easy way
to make a lot of money big mistake don't
do that it's the fastest way to go broke
so Warren Buffett did not invest in
Amazon but he's still done pretty well
for himself he didn't invest in Amazon
because he doesn't like Tech he doesn't
know it he doesn't love it he doesn't
live in that space and so he doesn't
want to buy those kinds of companies and
great he missed out on Amazon but he
also missed out on all the tech
companies that didn't make it that he
could have put money into that just
would have gone to zero he knows what
he's great at he knows what he loves and
he sticks in his Arena I'll look at what
I'm doing there's so many opportunities
that come my way that I know nothing
about I have no interest in I don't want
to have interest in that I'm I'm losing
money on right I don't like real estate
I hate real estate I don't wanna I don't
want to be in it I don't want to learn
about it I don't like real estate it's
not that it's not a good opportunity
it's just not for me it's boring to me I
have zero interest in real estate it's
great for so many people so many people
have built amazing wealth and
generational wealth based off of real
estate amazing I'm pumped for you it's
just not the thing that I want to be in
cryptocurrency right people when Bitcoin
was taken off everybody was a
cryptocurrency expert I know nothing
about cryptocurrency I bought zero
cryptocurrency in my life I've been
given zero cryptocurrency in my life is
cryptocurrency the future yep when is it
gonna come I don't know is it going to
be Bitcoin I don't know I I don't know
anything about the cryptocurrency I get
the mechanics and the general theory and
I know that it's coming but it's not the
opportunity for me
CBD is a big thing now right everybody's
getting the CBD and CBD oils and CBD
products and great and it's becoming
legal here in Canada it already is legal
in a bunch of our provinces and it's
going to be legalized across many states
if not the whole country
awesome it's not me I don't I don't I'm
not in the CBD I don't I don't smoke any
marijuana I never have I'm not
interested in it it may help you it may
alleviate your pain amazingness may be
the greatest gift you've ever seen in
your life amazing but if you're only
jumping into it because you think it's a
hot opportunity you're gonna
that being said I'm also involved in so
many things that are hot opportunities
I'm drowning in Opportunities I have too
many opportunities that I know what to
do with let alone don't know what to do
with looking at YouTube YouTube right
now is still a massive opportunity
there's so many people who look at what
I've done who look at what Gary have
done and Grant Cardone and those guys
have done they say I want to do it
YouTube is blowing up it's popping it's
exploding if you're a thought leader if
you want to have educational content
YouTube is still a huge opportunity most
people who are the experts at what they
do are not on YouTube that means you can
go on even with a little bit less
expertise and go and crush it because
the people who are the best in the world
are doing it they're not doing it it's a
huge opportunity it's a big white space
still right now even though I've been on
it for 10 years YouTube has evolved a
lot over the past decade and there's
still tons of white space open and
available I need to push the opportunity
harder have a good thought leadership is
another one thought leadership the stuff
that I'm doing the videos like this the
teaching that I've done the workshops
that I've done people want to be a
thought leader not just an influencer
but a thought leader and I'm at the
center of that Trend I'm helping train a
lot of thought leaders people are coming
to me asking me for help in becoming a
thought leader in making content and
being able to do good videos you'll be
able to get speaking gigs book deals all
of it people want it it's happening and
I'm at the center of that Trend too
League of Legends I love League of
Legends I've been playing League of
Legends for this is six years this is my
six year playing League of Legends I've
played Teemo look I got I got I got
Teemo here I got Timo here I got
Tristana here I've named my dogs Timo
and Tristana right I play three games a
night on my twitch stream you can come
to my twitch stream twitch.tv slash
believeteam come join me I play there
three games a night I'm trying to get
the gold uh this season which means I'm
in the top 10 of players uh in North
America so that's my it's my ambition
for the year I watch League of Legends
every weekend I have a TSM Jersey let me
get it
I have a TSM Jersey I'm a fan I love
League of Legends I love Esports if you
are getting to Esports just because it's
a hot opportunity and you don't love it
you're gonna die You're Gonna Lose
I look at garyvee as an example and
Gary's done an amazing job in hip-hop an
amazing job in hip-hop and he's brought
so many different artists on from the
top of nipsy hustle all the way down to
people who are just breaking in and
trying to get their start he loves
hip-hop he loves the lyrics he loves the
culture and so he's really built a name
for himself inside of hip-hop he got
into twitch a little bit he had a twitch
Studio set up in his office and he
started doing a little bit of gaming but
he's not a gamer he hasn't done gaming
in decades and so it's not authentic for
him and so he's not gonna win there I
love Esports I love League of Legends I
love gaming it's part of what I do I can
talk to you about the current roster for
TSM and my thoughts on it I could talk
about the new patch that came out on
League of Legends and how Timo is doing
I like it it's just I I genuinely like
it and so I have these opportunities in
front of me already within YouTube
within thought leadership within Esports
that that I can take advantage of and
blow up in and I don't need to worry
about real estate and cryptocurrency and
CBD and all the other millions of
opportunities out there there's already
tons of opportunities inside the things
that you already know and love the
things that you know and love there's
lots of people who know and love that
thing too
and they're looking for guidance they're
looking for help they need answers you
could be the person who gives them the
answers
jumping on some train because you think
it's a hot opportunity and a chance to
make money is the fastest way that you
will lose money because you don't
understand anything about that if you
don't love Esports don't go spend money
on an Esports team You're Gonna Lose You
don't even know what you're doing
inside the things that you love and know
is a tremendous opportunity and that's
what you need to focus on
you are what you consistently do it's
not what you do some of the times it's
not what you do when you feel motivated
or you had enough sleep or that it's the
perfect conditions out there you are
where you consistently do the one-off
moments don't mean anything you can have
a chocolate bar but if the rest of your
days are eaten healthy all the time
guess what you're not going to gain a
ton of weight and likewise the other way
around if you have a life that you're
not following through on any of your
goals and then you have one great moment
or one great day guess what you fall
back down this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle because you have
these moments where you feel alive
empowered on top of the world amazing
and you might even put a little bit of
that into practice but if it's not
consistent
then it never happens and it's almost
better to not even know what you're
capable of this is the part of the curse
of being an entrepreneur is you know
you're capable of great things you see
an amazing future amazing world of what
you could build
but then you also see your lack of
follow-through and the lack of delivery
and the lack of execution and it's that
constant grind against your self-worth
to say I should be doing more but I'm
not it's almost better to have no goals
and have no dreams and have no ambition
because then you're good then you're in
in Bliss because you're ignorant of
what's what you're capable of
so how do you fix it I look at myself
and anytime I want to make a change in
my life it goes to the schedule
my schedule has to map to my ambitions
right your schedule needs to map to your
missions what you say you wanted a life
needs to be in your life
right hope is not is not enough hoping
that you have enough inspiration hoping
that you get motivated hoping that
you'll be ready one day that's not
enough it's not a day of the week right
some day is not it's not a day of the
week Sunday is but someday is not a day
of the week and so whatever you wanted a
life has to be in your calendar whatever
success looks like for you how finances
relationships whatever it looks like for
you whatever that perfect vision is in
your head whatever you have on your
dream board of what you want to
accomplish in your life okay great how
do you accomplish that how do you get
there it's your habits success is habits
success equals habits
where are your habits in your calendar
so what are you doing
when you wake up in the morning what are
you doing every single day of the week
what are you doing for planning for your
for you know the the quarter and the
week and the even the year ahead what
are you doing what are you doing to
change what's in your calendar to make
sure that if you actually did those
things like if you look at your week
look at your next week
look at what's in your calendar
your health goals your your relationship
goals not just the goals but the
execution against it you can say you
want to have a great body or you want to
get healthy this year great what does
that look like where in your calendar
are you spending time planning your food
and working out and taking care of
yourself it has to be a time not just
not just a blank space this is the
problem we'll book a lot of our business
stuff but not our personal stuff I book
all my personal stuff my time with Nina
is in my calendar the time to celebrate
with the kids and families in the
calendar it's in the calendar it's as
important as a business meeting because
what happens is when you have blank
spots in your calendar
you start living an unintentional life
right when you set up a calendar and you
create the blocks of time for where
you're going to spend when you're going
to wake up and what you're going to work
on and when you're going to take care of
your body and when you're going to take
care of your relationships or take care
of self
right if when that's in your calendar
that's living an intentional life
when you just have a bunch of blank
spots
you get distracted pull up your phone
and dive into Instagram and three hours
later you're still on it and you feel
worse about yourself so it's about
creating an intentional life for
yourself and that starts with your
calendar you are what you consistently
do you are what you repeatedly do so how
do we do it how are some of the steps
what what are the three action items for
you well step one is to figure out what
do you want
especially on a belief scale like what
do you want to believe
what is the difference between where you
are now and where you want to go and
this can be hard for Achievers because
you probably
are the most ambitious person that you
know right you're the one who's caring
about other people you're the one
encouraging other people but nobody's
doing it for you so what are the beliefs
that you need to have what's the most
important belief change that you need to
have that you're not getting from your
immediate circle doesn't mean you stop
pointing to the people keep doing it
it's amazing you're built to serve it's
going to fill you up but you need
something to pour into you otherwise you
don't grow
right if you're just feeding other
people and nothing's feeding you you
don't grow you're just gonna get drained
so what's going to be feeding into you
the belief
that would make the difference between
where you are right now and where you
want to be what is that single belief
great so getting clear on what that one
don't don't worry about having a hundred
different beliefs yet tackle one thing
at a time what's the single most
important belief that you need to have
for yourself to get your next level of
growth great step number two
who is doing that right now
who was doing that and creating an
environment and habits around it so for
me I want to believe in myself more I
want to spread more belief to other
people as well so what's in my
environment well my physical environment
you can see here from me wearing this
outfit to having you know the pictures
behind me on the wall these people all
inspire me for different reasons to the
videos that I make and consume to the
work that I do in my community to the
new Discord that I set up Evan
carmichael.biz if you want to come and
join us uh that's part of what I do
every day to make me feel like I believe
in myself more believe in in me as a
human believe in the work that I'm doing
believe that it will work out I want
more belief and I've designed habits and
rituals to help me get it where most
people again do not wake up and feel
like today is going to be an amazing day
and they're just bursting full of energy
and on top of the world from the moment
they wake up no I woke up this morning
it was just past seven
um I don't sleep to an alarm so I woke
up and just I wake up when my body tells
me to wake up so I woke up just past
seven
um I didn't know what day it was you
know I'm tired I wake up I go to the
bathroom and on my way I put on an oldie
song and and all these music gets me
moving gets me bouncing gets me jiving
and then immediately start going to
community stuff right I'm in the
bathroom I'm listening to my oldies I
look at my intention for the day today
I'm recording YouTube videos how do I
want to show up what I want to do who do
I want to be showing up on the content
and then go to community
and I go I joined my Discord and I'm
giving love to people because it makes
me feel like what I do matters and it
makes me feel more belief right I've got
videos on that very remind me of who I
want to be I'm around my heroes and
mentors but deciding
the difference that you need to believe
between now and where you're going and
then two putting it into your calendar
especially the morning routine of how
you're going to show up so it's not an
accident so that you don't hope that
that you show up and you do it today but
that it's it's marked in your calendar
and in step three and this is the
hardest for a lot of people is you do
what's in your calendar here's a really
important rule that if you do this it
will change your life
when you are deciding
what to do in your calendar on the day
of
you cannot change what's in today's
calendar you can change tomorrows but
you can't change today here's what I
mean if you're looking at your calendar
and you set out your goals right here
here's who I want to be this week here's
what I want to get done this week I want
to wake up at this time and I want to
work out and I want to connect with my
family and I want to serve and whatever
whatever the chunks of time are for you
there's a tendency to in the moment
change
where on Sunday you looked at your
calendar and said here's what I'm going
to do this is going to be an exciting
week it's great but then come Thursday
morning you don't want to wake up at
that time or you see what's in the
calendar I don't want to go for that run
I don't want to make those calls I don't
want to make those videos and then you
don't and you quickly fall off track
sound familiar is it making sense it
looks so great on the weekend when you
plan this but now when you're actually
doing it you don't do it
and then what happens is the next time
you say you're going to do something you
don't believe yourself because you let
yourself off the hook too easily
so the rule becomes
you can only change tomorrow's calendar
not today you're tired
you had a rough day
you don't think this workout's working
for you anymore you don't think making
videos is aligned with you anymore great
tomorrow you don't have to do it
tomorrow you can change but today you're
doing it because you said you were going
to do it tomorrow you can sleep in
because today you had a last night you
had a rough night so today you're extra
tired but you're still getting up when
you said you're gonna get up and you
still do the things that are in your
calendar and then tomorrow you can sleep
in and tomorrow you can adjust
the workout the business plan whatever
if it doesn't feel right anymore but not
today don't trust yourself in the moment
because your brain is going to tell you
to play small your brain is going to
remind you why you can't do these things
your brain is going to find a reason for
you to let yourself off the hook again
like it did last time
you know what you want
that's what you said you were going to
do on the weekend when you look at your
calendar you have to show up the day of
so you have to get really clear on the
belief that you want to have that will
make the difference for you you need to
surround yourself with those Heroes and
role models and change your morning
routine to reflect it and then you need
to actually do what's in your calendar
and if something's off or it doesn't
work you change it for tomorrow but you
can't change it in the moment you are
what you consistently do
you know you've got so much inside you
and so much that you want to share and
serve and help
and you keep letting yourself down
and it's it's time to change it you're
ready to change it you're ready to move
past it you're ready to be the person
who follows through you're ready to be
the person who with that big dream
starts to make momentum towards it
the only difference is being the person
who does what you consistently say you
will do your energy changes how you show
up
when you are happy positive optimistic
full of life Creative Energy you you
make amazing things
but when you feel negative down
depressed side for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not something new that I'm
telling you you know this the challenges
we are not in a high energy state
consistently enough to stay consistent
on our goals so follow through to create
the momentum because we allow outside
forces as well as our internal voice to
keep us small to keep us protected to
keep us scared to depress our courage
muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and a desire to serve it doesn't
happen it doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people
with a worse version of your idea but
just more energy and go off and do it
have you ever seen it happen you ever
seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action it just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so if energy is so important then
how do we how do we manage your energy
how do we keep it high and doesn't mean
that you always have to be on top of the
world and you don't have to delude
yourself and say I'm amazing this is
going to be the greatest day of all time
like you don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you didn't need to do is be in
the right energy to serve your mission
and whatever you're doing today so let
me use me as an example and today
uh it's a great example because I did
not sleep well last night had had two
and a half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and and just could not could not
get to sleep so I slept from like 6 30
to 9 o'clock did not sleep until 6 30 in
the morning
and that is thankfully a rare occurrence
you know most nights I get eight hours
sleep seven and a half to eight and a
half hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something that would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen
so if you start to train yourself when
you create a calendar and say okay
today is a blank I'm filming this on a
Tuesday today's a Tuesday Tuesday's my
video day no matter what I'm filming
videos I gotta film videos it's got to
happen it may not be my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with a video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside you know get outside
get fresh air get some sun on my face if
you you know if you want to change your
energy you want to shift where you're at
and how you're thinking because it's
part physical energy but also just
mental energy how do you feel about what
you're doing and what's going to happen
today and getting out of your home
changing your physical environment and
getting some sun on your face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier a little bit more in
the right energy space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song you feel chill you put on a Chill
song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called hashtag believe all
caps on the on the letters believe
that's all the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that if they came on it would make me
move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work that
I'm about to do
but it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is
you know who you're feeding your mind
with who are you around who you're
surrounded by both the people in your
life you know actual humans
and the videos that you watch or books
that you read and the podcasts you
consume I remember on the weekend
you gotta guard against this it's crazy
so on the weekend I went to go
meet an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and
my whole day ended up being thrown off
until I caught it at night to say why
why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back that oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you could have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
Ripple effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with who you're
watching on YouTube or podcasts Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this
thinking this way I don't like it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I applied a lot of the same things I got
it I went outside went outside reset get
some fresh air it always helps me put on
some music songs that I actually like
not some fake song that somebody else
likes and says dance to this it'll make
you feel good songs that I actually like
there are some songs that if it came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go [ __ ] and crazy but
there's some songs that if it came on
you would Bob your head or you would tap
your feet or bounce your knee there's
some songs that just make you do that
right so put on one of those songs it
would naturally make you feel happier
so I did that too and then in terms of
just gardening against people I made a
note that hey the next time I go see
this verse he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
which is not often but still the next
time I see him I need to remind myself
of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not going to allow his
negativity to to break my shield you
know to permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiley and happy had dreams for
the future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
get squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but having positive
energy is natural having sunshine and
leading to happiness is natural putting
on music and and dancing and moving is
natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the I was like
it's okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day
you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
but you're on top of the world and the
fake high every day but a better energy
state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much does your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy most people
sleepwalk through life because they
don't love what they're doing you wake
up and you don't love what you're doing
you feel like it doesn't matter you feel
like nobody will care if you show up or
you don't and if if that was your day
if you today felt like you know what it
doesn't matter I show up I don't show up
I make I don't make nobody's gonna
really care if that was not just today
but tomorrow the next day the next day
the next day if that was every day of
your life how sad would your life be
this is why we have so much anxiety and
depression and suicide is because people
feel like they don't matter and we want
to matter to others is wired into us we
want to feel like we are important we
want to feel like what we're going to do
today is going to create some kind of
meaning and impact on somebody else's
life we are built to serve you want to
help it's not enough to want to do
something just for yourself you want to
feel like you matter to somebody else
today
most people sleepwalk through their
lives
never feeling like they meant anything
to anybody especially in their work
and it's why a lot of people default to
entrepreneurship to try to say well
here's my chance to be to be My Own Boss
use my chance to live my own life here's
my chance to do something that matters
without just being some Cog in a
corporate machine
but unless you connect the work that
you're doing to serving and helping
other people you still won't feel great
when I first started in my business it
was really really hard
um
both businesses but the business where I
helped Inspire entrepreneurs and I got
asked to speak and I remember just
loving the speaking part and at the time
I was doing a speaking gig a month or so
and just wasn't getting enough feedback
I'd go and it'd be amazing I'd be so so
nervous and so scared to get up on stage
but then the end would be so amazing and
to see that you helped somebody you know
how good it feels to help somebody
you know how good it feels to make
somebody smile or laugh or cry or
for them just to say thank you
you know you know you know how good it
feels when somebody says thank you for
what you've done for me today
that is more valuable than whatever
they're paying you for your product or
service right we all want that that's
the good thing to get addicted to so
when I first started speaking and
helping
I I was getting that once a month and
doing a speaking gig but then I wasn't
feeling it throughout the month this is
the hard part of being an entrepreneur
especially at the beginning when you
don't have enough feedback you're not
feeling valuable it takes too long to
get your product to service or service
to Market to see the at the action that
your customers are getting from it
and so I had to remind myself of what I
was doing I had to remind myself I made
a PowerPoint file where I looked at my
comments every day the feedback that I
was getting even though it was for three
weeks ago I still looked at the feedback
again to remind myself of what I was
doing was important when I started my
YouTube Channel I didn't get any
feedback I wasn't getting any comments
right my first video took a year to get
three comments and it was my mom my
older sister and then some random guy so
I wasn't getting a lot of feedback
but I still would look at my comments
every day
just to feel like hey this is important
like if I got one comment a week I'd be
so happy it's like yeah I see that
person I helped that person
I gotta keep going I gotta keep making
got to keep creating
and even to this day it still was among
the most important things that I do
I'm I'm pretty in love with Discord
right now I created my own Discord
server you can join believe Nation it's
Evan carmichael.biz it's free and I'm in
there every morning right now
just helping and it's one of my
go-to's right now for how I start my day
start my day I look at my calendar I set
my intention for the day and then I'll
go to my Discord server and start
helping people
because
having a million views on a video or
however many subscribers or whatever it
does not feel as good as
going into Discord server and helping
one person believing themselves a little
bit more
so you have to figure out a way to make
it
not a Sleepwalk every day
to make it feel like you're doing
something that matters that you matter
that today is going to matter that you
show up in a way that matters so let me
break down a couple things that I think
can help number one is the big picture
has to matter
this is why people struggle in jobs
because you feel like nobody cares right
this job doesn't mean anything
the company doesn't care if I'm here or
not even the company's Mission isn't
that important you don't feel connected
to what you're doing every day you have
to feel connected to the mission
if you're an entrepreneur it's a lot
easier but you have to be doing work
that you actually think matters a lot of
entrepreneurs start a company just
trying to make money you're just trying
to pay the bills you're just trying to
make some cash you're just trying to
look at the hot opportunity and if you
can't connect to the reason why you're
doing it the mission you won't win the
number one rule for success is you have
to love the thing that you're doing if
you're doing it just to make money
making money is important it is
important you have to do it it needs to
be in your top five but it can't be
number one what is number one
you have to design your business that
you feel like you're on a mission that
you're here to serve that you're doing
some kind of good that you you may not
be there yet you may not be
accomplishing anything close to it yet
but it's the goal it's the mission that
you're trying to go off and achieve
so number one is you have to feel like
on a big scale on a macro scale that if
it all plays out this is going to really
really really really really matter to
you but to other people as well
two is the micro wins have to be there
you know it's the it's the Big Y and the
little y so the first one is the Big Y
the big why what am I trying to
accomplish the second one is a little
wide little wise the daily little wins
you could be
inspired by your big why
it could be driving you it could be
feeling you but
there will be many days where the Big Y
is not enough
there'll be many days where you feel
like you can't do that big why that who
were you to think you could do that
crazy big thing that it's never going to
happen that you're not going to make it
that it's just it's just not worth it
there'll be many days when you feel like
that
especially when you don't see any
tractional momentum happening
that's what the little y's come into
place the little Y is the daily little
feeling like hey I did something to help
one person I may not be able to impact
the world today I may not be having a
life-changing product or service or
launch or video or whatever but I can
help one person today that's why I go to
the Discord every morning that's why I'm
in my comments every day because
my big why is to change the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I'm never going to do
it and there are days where that feels
way too big and too scary I channel that
into this like this video I want this
video to matter I'm sitting here in the
parking lot in my car while Nina's at a
a pet store getting stuff for the dogs
right I'm just talking to my cell phone
but I want this video to matter I want
this video to touch you I want this
video to have some kind of meaningful
impact that maybe this is the day the
way that I say the words the energy that
I show up with maybe maybe just maybe
this is a day that you finally go off
and make some kind of change maybe today
is the day that's my sincere hope
and
I need to still feel like I'm touching
somebody that talking to my phone is not
enough so going to the Discord server
talking to people encouraging them
giving them some love just saying good
morning just helping people
it's crazy doing DMS in the morning on
my Instagram and spending eight seconds
making a video for somebody and then
seeing the reaction like you don't know
how much this video meant to me that you
would send us it's coming to me at the
right time today I really needed that
encouragement
took me eight seconds to do but it
changed somebody's life right is that
going to help me grow my subscribers or
comments or Revenue no right but it
feels really good
and you need those little y's so what
are the things that
are connected to your big mission
but are really small but it's a it's an
individual that you can help one person
that by you helping one person today
you've got your little why that can give
you the motivation to keep going
how do we stop sleepwalking through life
right Big Y you're on a big mission that
you're trying to accomplish something
huge step two is a little why we feel
like today is going to matter to
somebody to one human even if it doesn't
accomplish our big mission step number
three is to pay it forward
you know how good it feels to get a
comment to get a video to get a
personalized message for someone to help
you out
Pay It Forward especially to small
creators my ask for you would be if you
if there's somebody that you follow
somebody who you who whose Journey
you're following along with maybe it's
your friend who's posting maybe it's
some total stranger who you've found
some of their content
go give them a little love
go get them a review on iTunes go give
them a comment on their YouTube or
Instagram or wherever you're following
them
it means so much
if it's a giant Channel
or someone's been doing it for a long
time you know I don't see all the
comments that come in don't don't leave
a comment on if you I mean leave a
comment on the videos but it doesn't
mean as much anymore as it used to right
because we get so many so we're spoiled
so the big the big creators don't worry
about it you can it's always good karma
that's to spread positivity but if you
had to pick
pick for the smaller ones
because just one person saying I see you
just one person saying thank you just
one person saying this message meant
something to me this just one just one
person
having that belief
is the difference quite often between
them quitting and them following through
your single message today to somebody
is going to be the difference I promise
you for somebody if you did that every
day it will for sure be the difference
for quite a number of people between
them quitting and then continuing on
because you took 15 seconds to send a
quick message to them
so Big Y little Y and then pay it
forward especially to the small creators
we got to get out of the Sleepwalk guys
we we want to feel like we matter we
want to feel like today matters we want
to feel like the work we do matters and
the best way that you can inspire people
you want to help the people around you
you want to help your community you want
to help your family you want to help the
people who might see you you want to
help people the best way to help them is
for you to stop sleepwalking is for you
to start doing things that matter it's
not for you to just
make a inspirational video
it's through your actions that if you
showed up today and decided that you're
going to remember your big why that
you're going to serve with your little
why that you're going to pay it forward
to other people
when you see the impact that that can
have on their life
it makes you reconnect to why you do
what you do
and if you woke up and did the thing
that made you remember why you do what
you do and you felt it not just words
you're telling yourself but you
genuinely felt it
holy cow look out because life starts to
get really really good
if you think money is scarce you hoard
it because you believe that no more
money will come to you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
um even growing up I grew up in a middle
class family my parents spent my parents
are behind me on the wall hold on there
we go this is me when I'm eight or nine
and my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education and as a result we
didn't have you know money for other
things and
um where my friends at these fancy
schools were getting you know BMWs for
their 16th birthday so they can go off
and drive uh you know I didn't get any
of that and it's not what was me but
it's more I just had a scarce mentality
around money in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I was eating
the same bean salad lunch every day
because it would fill me up and wasn't
very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
McDonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to McDonald's and Order
large fries and share that between the
three of us because it was cheap and we
wanted just some little way to celebrate
and
I just remember how painful it was to
feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it
and again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that I've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and spend
uh either for ourselves or for other
people
and so my default is to invest invest
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into into
into markets invest in the assets just
invest invest invest invest invest
invest
the that's a good that's a great good
mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know
um on the weekend Nina bought a very
expensive purse
we went shopping she had a very
offensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spending this amount
of money on a bag
but it's worth
celebrating yourself so you know what
like we earned that we did so much work
in our business you can you can go and
afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
Charities we've also used the money to
uh support our family and things that
they needed or wanted in their lives and
it's something that we have to spend
every month
Nina asked hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month and so where
we have to sit this might sound crazy we
have to sit down every month and figure
out how are we going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to invest or just
to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be 100 bucks a month that you force
yourself to spend on making somebody
else's life better or even your own like
that thing that you would never buy for
yourself you know what I've worked hard
like I'm gonna buy it or you're gonna go
buy somebody a meal or you're gonna go
and give a homeless person a hundred
dollars right like you're gonna you're
gonna do something with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel like
more will come
that I'm creating
and so whether it's 10 bucks 100 bucks a
thousand bucks 10 000 bucks like you
know whatever it is I'm not advocating
you go drain your bank account and just
go crazy and buy a Chanel bag you know
but allocating a certain percentage
every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teaching them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them 2500
bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build a bigger business right so the the
core of your business needs to be
serving and helping and contributing
back and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so this
gives that little extra bit of
motivation and incentive right to get
out there and start to do it to allocate
a certain percentage second is to be
around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love
my view on something great hanging
around me more often there's lots of
videos you love Grant cardone's view or
garyvee's view or Oprah's view on
something the more you hang around them
and watch their content and read their
books and listen to their speeches the
more you're going to start to adopt that
same belief system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce and the people that I grew up
with believe that money is really scarce
the closest people around me and so it
doesn't mean you stop hanging out with
them but you need to inject new people
in even if it's just through YouTube
videos
are the people who believe the thing
that you want to believe because
otherwise you get pulled back down
because your environment has been
created to keep you where you are so if
you want to change where you are you
have to change the environment
and it used to be that you had to you
have to really change you have to go
somewhere else you had to move out you
had to find a mentor to hang out with
and have coffee with consistently now
you can do it through through YouTube
I've been inspired by tons of mentors
who have never met
because of the content that I've learned
from them on YouTube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day
being intention with that to say this is
this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because their belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
I think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
I've I've lived through really intense
versions of it I still feel like I'm
coming out of it
I've grown a lot compared to where I
used to be but still have a lot a long
ways to go I probably still have things
that I'm holding on to that I shouldn't
uh I probably still should be more
generous than I am
um and I'm I'm working through it as
well I might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve definitely
compared to 19 year old Evan who thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can learn to make that rewiring
happen that's how you start to change
your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to
help more people with it start to allow
the money to flow
because when you start to believe that
you can create a lot more money for
yourself
a lot of things start to change
[Music]
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there believe is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that I make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that I make is about
belief it has to be every interaction I
have every Workshop every book